Hey everyone, Ryan here, and welcome to our bonus practice questions video for the patient
management series.
Now, in this video, we're going to test everything that you've learned in the last 10 videos.
We've covered a lot of things in this series.
If you haven't already, I would definitely recommend watching those videos first.
I broke down the material covered on the board exam into 10 videos of high yield information,
and as you'll see, this information will really help you on the board exam.
So I compiled 15 questions for us to go through from old release questions, practice books,
and questions that I modeled after actual exam questions when I took the exam.
So these are going to be very similar to what you see on test day.
So with that, let's get started.
So question number one, which of the following American Dental Association principles of
ethics states that a dentist has a duty to respect the patient's right to self-determination
and confidentiality?
So go ahead and pause the video, think through the question, and then we'll go over it together.
So if you've watched any of my practice question videos, you know that my number one strategy
is to break down the question and start with what you know.
Now if we didn't do that and we just jumped right ahead to the answers, well, privacy
sounds pretty good because, well, that's what confidentiality is all about, right?
But C is a classic trap answer because privacy is not a principle of ethics.
And that's essential to answering this question.
Privacy is actually part of HIPAA.
So I would go through first and rule out any answers that are not ADA principles of ethics.
Now non-molephatants means do no harm, justice is fairness, veracity is truthfulness, and
patient autonomy, the last one here that we're going to talk about is self-determination
and confidentiality.
Now all four of these are principles of ethics.
So of the four remaining certainly makes sense that patient autonomy, their rights to their
own patient information and they're making their own informed decisions, that certainly
fits the bill with self-determination and confidentiality.
So if we go through the answer with a routine sense of breaking down the question, finding
the key concepts that the test makers are trying to test, and then looking for the answers
logically, we get to the correct answer being patient autonomy.
All right, question number two, during an informal session of motivational interviewing,
your patient says, "I don't have time to quit smoking.
What stage of behavior change is he or she in?"
So go ahead and pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
So the test maker was very thoughtful in this case and ordered the answer choices in the
correct order for you.
Now this doesn't always happen this way, but it's great when it does.
So we'll take advantage of this.
Pre-contemplation is when you're not even considering behavior change, contemplations
when you're starting to consider it, preparation is when you're preparing to take steps to
change, action is when you're engaged in physical action towards that behavior change, and maintenance
is maintaining that changed behavior.
And this is the classic, we looked at this cycle that happens when someone is going through
some type of pivotal change in behavior in their lives.
Now the behavior change in this example is to quit smoking.
Now the patient says, "I don't have time for that," while they're actively opposed
to it.
And so they're not even considering quitting smoking at this time in their lives.
So this would put them at the pre-contemplation stage.
So the answer here is A. Now as a side note, when you're studying
with these practice questions, one really valuable study strategy is what I call flipping
a practice question inside out.
So if the answer is A, which in this case it is, how would I change the question prompt
this part here, in order to make the answer B, what would I have to change in the wording
here to make B the correct answer?
How would I make the correct answer B, C, et cetera, and you can go through each answer
choice that way.
And that can help you get even more mileage out of any practice question you come across.
So give it a shot and let me know what you think of flipping the questions inside out
as part of your studying.
And here's that circle I was talking about with the stages of change in behavior.
Alright question number three, the blank section of a scientific article provides the reader
with detailed information regarding the study design.
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll talk about this.
Alright so, these are all five distinct sections of a paper, abstract of course appears at
the beginning of the paper, it's the SparkNotes version that everybody tends to read, it provides
a quick summary with not any detailed information.
So I could pretty confidently rule out abstract, it's not going to be providing that sort of
detail we're looking for in the question.
Now background and introduction, I said distinct before but they're actually synonymous, they're
basically providing a background on the topic, why it's important and relevant, it's talking
about aims of the study, the hypothesis or hypotheses, again we're not getting detailed
information regarding the specifics of the design of the paper.
So these are also incorrect.
Now the discussion section is interpreting and making sense of results and findings, again
not really regarding the study design per se, so that one, I'm not too fond of that
answer to choice either, where the methods, you know, routinely call materials and methods
or just methods provide specific information about the population being tested, the independent
and dependent variables, sampling method, experimental design, statistical analysis,
all those numbers, and like I said in our evidence based dentistry video, it's arguably
one of the most important and honestly underestimated sections of the scientific paper.
So if we're looking for detailed information regarding the study design, this is certainly
the place to look, so the answer here is D.
All right question number four, which of the following is an effective community prevention
program?
Go ahead and pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
All right so the tricky part of this question is that all of these answers are good prevention
protocols, but the key word here is community.
Only one of these is a community level prevention program.
The others are all at the individual level, so you can think of the individual level as
something a dentist would tell an individual patient during their checkup visit, so they
would tell them, well you should brush twice a day, you should floss every night, keep
seeing us for regular checkups and maintain a low sugar diet, but school sealant program,
that's a little bit different and it's a very effective community level program because it
covers multiple people at once, once it's in place you're covering multiple children
at school that can receive these sealants.
Now it's not quite as effective as community water fluoridation, which we said before is
our most cost-effective community prevention protocol, but school sealant program is certainly
another example of that, so our answer here is D.
Question number five, which method of sterilization is least likely to dull and corrode carbide
instruments?
Go ahead and pause the video and then we'll talk about this.
Alright so this is a nice little infection control question here, corrosion is a natural
chemical process where the metal deteriorates, it forms an oxide, and it's usually caused
by contact with an acid, but it could be something like water or some other liquid.
Now in the case of steam heat, we're essentially putting these instruments through a pressurized
sauna, ethylene oxide is also very humid, it's not as hot, but it does have a high moisture
content, and glutaraldehyde, well we're essentially bathing instruments in this liquid.
Now dry heat is the only one here that has very low, low moisture, as the name suggests,
and has the best preservation of cutting edges as a result.
So if we didn't know specifically this high yield fact, we could try to group things together,
see if we can get three of them on the same page, in this case three methods that involve
high humidity or moisture, and find the one that doesn't belong, and in this case dry
heat is the best example of that.
So the best preservation of cutting instruments and the least likely to dull and corrode is
the dry heat method of sterilization.
Alright question number six, what is an example of a conditioned stimulus for a dental patient
that had a previous bad experience at the dentist?
So go ahead, pause the video, and then we'll go over this together.
Alright so this is a good question looking at the concept of classical conditioning.
So the example I use in dentistry is, the dentist gives you an injection, which is an
unconditioned stimulus, but it's painful and causes anxiety, which is an unconditioned
natural stimulus for somebody.
Now there's also a neutral stimulus present, which is the presence of the dentist who gives
the injection, and that dentist is usually wearing a white coat to give said injection.
So once this is repeated multiple times, that patient is getting multiple injections from
a dentist with a white coat, the mere presence of the dentist will eventually cause anxiety
for the patient by itself, because now we're linking that previously neutral stimulus,
and now the dentist is becoming the conditioned stimulus.
But if we're being honest, there are multiple conditions stimuli that are appearing in this
example.
Not only the dentist administering the injection and the white coat they're wearing, but also
just going to the dental office, waiting in the waiting room, getting called back and
sitting in the dental chair, these are all things that are happening every time you're
experiencing the injection or the drilling, whatever really bothers you.
And so all of these things become conditioned stimuli.
Now with that in mind, well, there's really only one answer that makes sense here for
a conditioned stimulus.
High blood pressure, intrinsic fear, anxiety of a parent, these are all things that are
more internalized fears, they're not linked to what's actually going on behind the scenes.
But the dental chair, like in our example, is something that's in the background of your
experience, it's in the circumstance and you're subconsciously linking that to this feeling
of pain and subsequent anxiety from the dental injection or whatever it might be.
And so in this example, dental chair makes the most sense for an example for a conditioned
stimulus.
And here's our example of Pavlov's dogs that we went over in detail in our behavior change
video.
All right, question number seven, which of the following is not included in the ADA code
of conduct?
Go ahead, pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
All right, so this one is actually a bit tricky, but I see this concept come up all the time.
So I definitely wanted to include it in our practice set.
So remember, the principle of ethics is our list of five principles.
And the code of conduct is the demonstration of those five principles in day to day dental
practice.
So let's go through these one by one licensure by credentials.
So this is essentially the requirements for getting a dental license, very state to state.
Not really sure about this one, let's come back to it advertising fees and patient care.
Now the dentists, dentists must not falsely represent care being rendered, fees being charged,
or advertising of their dental practice.
These are scenarios where the dentist is ethically required to be truthful for the patient and
the community at large.
So these are all examples of the ethical principle of veracity or truthfulness.
So those are certainly included in the code of conduct and they actually are if you went
on the ADA website, you looked at the code of conduct, there are specific subsections
for each of these.
Now what does slander mean?
That means you're saying something bad about another dentist or another dental professional.
This is also something we should not be doing under the code of conduct.
This is an ethical requirement not to slander another dental professional.
And this is under the ethical principle of justice or fairness.
So that is also included.
Now licensure by credentials, as I alluded to before, it varies from state to state.
It's not really an ethical concern.
There are certain requirements that you need to uphold and meet, but they're not under
the five ethical principles.
So the answer here is A.
Alright question number eight.
Which technique is typically not useful in treating an anxious patient?
Alright, so go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
Alright, so let's go through the answer choices because these are a little bit longer.
A is using less structure in establishing rapport, B reassuring the patient by telling
the patient not to worry, C providing reasons before asking for sensitive information,
using empathy or making expectations clear.
This is a little bit tricky if you're just looking at it and kind of thinking well they
all sound pretty good, right?
Like all of these would potentially help an anxious patient out using less structure in
establishing rapport.
So that's kind of talking about well we really want to just be open with the patient, try
to get to know them, write rapport is all about establishing that initial level of trust.
And an anxious patient, trust is incredibly important, potentially someone who's an anxious
patient like we talked about in one of our previous practice questions.
They could have had a bad experience, they could have had a previous dentist where things
really didn't go well and so they might have a lot of questions, a lot of reservations,
a wall built up between you and the patient.
So rapport and taking time to get to know them can be a really useful trick.
So I think that's a great thing to do.
See providing reasons before asking for sensitive information.
This is another thing that's providing trust, right?
You're giving somebody, you're not just asking personal information from the patient right
off the bat, you're letting them know well hey we really need to know this for comprehensiveness
of care and we really appreciate any input you might have.
Using empathy is one of those answers that you can never really say that's not a good
thing.
Empathy is always a great thing to use.
And making expectations clear is another one of those kind of, yeah that sounds good,
that's something I can't really argue against that, I can't really say that's not a useful
thing to treat an anxious patient.
So the only thing that really sticks out to me is reassuring the patient by telling them
not to worry and don't worry is a classic trap response.
That's a really easy thing for a dentist to say oh don't worry it'll be fine, you'll be
just fine.
And providing this premature reassurance can actually compromise trust and rapport with
the patient.
If it's not consistent with what actually happens, right, if they're actually in a lot
of pain and it wasn't easy and they didn't feel fine, then they're not going to trust
you next time you say something like that.
So it's better to be upfront with them, establish rapport, make them know that you're in it
for them, right, you're not trying to be standoffish, you're actually trying to help them, you're
not trying to hurt them.
And so if they know you're on their side, but they also know that the appointment's not
necessarily going to be enjoyable, then they're more likely to be on your team.
So the best answer here is to not provide premature reassurance and be honest and upfront
with them, provide empathy and give them someone to trust.
So the answer here is B.
All right, question number nine.
The variance for data set A is 21 and for data set B is seven.
From this, we can conclude which of the following.
Go ahead and pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
All right, so this is a nice little statistical question here.
And if you know what variance is, this answer is actually pretty straightforward.
So variance is one of those measures of dispersion, how spread out certain numbers are in a given
data set.
And the larger that number is, that means the more spread out the numbers in that data
set are.
So if we know that, we can narrow down to the correct answer.
So we know A has a higher variance than C. So which of the following is true?
There are more items in data set than data set B. No, we don't know that specifically.
That's not what variance is talking about.
The mean of data set is smaller than the mean.
No, this is a measure of central tendency.
That's not, that doesn't have to do with variance here.
I think, I think what they're trying to say here is that, oh, if the variance is seven
here for B and it's 21 for A, then maybe the, actually this is supposed to say the mean
of data set B is smaller than the mean of data set A. But regardless, that answer choice
is incorrect either way.
And C, the items in data set A are more widely spread about the mean value than the items
in data set B. Now that sounds pretty good because we know that if the number variance
is higher than the values are more spread out and the standard deviation for data set
B is larger than the standard deviation for data set A, that's actually incorrect.
A should have the larger standard deviation because that's another measure of central
tendency. So the answer is C.
Alright question number 10, which of the following is an arrangement between a plan
and a group of dentists whereby the providers agree to accept certain payments usually less
than their usual fees in anticipation of a higher volume of patience?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
Alright so let's start with B first, capitation is a per capita payment plan. So that's not
really relevant for this question, it's asking about an arrangement and more sort of the
organization of the dentist, the structure of the dental care. So capitation is a payment
plan that's not relevant. Medicare is a government health program and although fees are lower,
you're not necessarily getting a higher volume of patience so that doesn't really fit with
the wording in this question. And in HMO is not an agreement between a plan and a group
of dentists, so that's not really correct either. And so we only have one good answer
here, the only correct answer is PPO, which from the red text in our insurance video is
a panel of providers that agree to accept less than usual fees in exchange for a higher
volume of patience. And that's because the subscribers to this plan have a financial
incentive to use providers from this panel and that's why the providers agree to accept
lower fees. So the wording is really important to nail down for what a PPO is, it's a very
specific arrangement and it certainly will come up on the board exam is exactly as I
have worded here. So the answer is A. Alright, next one, which of the following is a component
of the ORS model? Go ahead, pause the video and then we'll go over this together. Alright,
so I think I mentioned when we talked about this in the health behavior change that I
got a question pretty much like this on the board exam. It kind of threw me a little bit
because I didn't memorize specifically what each of these things means. So I'm hoping
that you don't make the same mistake I did because this is a really simple question to
get if you've memorized what ORS stands for. But if not, well let's see if we can narrow
down the choices. Well, the ORS model refers to motivational interviewing, which is a form
of counseling for patients to help them go from a mindset of indifference to a mindset
of change. So you help them arrive at a new mindset on their own. So let's go through
the answers and see if we can narrow down what this could potentially be referring to.
So assertions, that's like a confident and forceful statement, doesn't really fit with
what we're going for. So I'm going to cross that one out for now. Appraisals is an act
of assessing something, examining or evaluating something. Maybe we'll put a question mark
there. Affirmations, this is like emotional support or encouragement. Well, that sounds
pretty good. That sounds about what we're going for. Absolutes, again, it's a bit too
strong of a word for what we're going for for a motivational sort of interviewing counseling
situation. And so ORS, if you've memorized it, is open questions, affirmations, reflective
listening and summarizing. So the answer here is C. Question number 12. Fluoride supplementation
for a two year old child who lives in a non-fluoridated community can best be accomplished by initially
prescribing which of the following. Go ahead, pause the video and then we'll go over this
together. All right. So if they're living in a non-fluoridated community, they're of
a certain age, they need some kind of supplementation. And so they list out the four or the five
common options for fluoride adjunctive therapy. Now let's go through each of these together
tablets for a two year old. That's going to be pretty hard to chew. So I don't think
that's the ideal situation to prescribe a two year old. Lossinges, the little like suck
on kind of candy looking things. That's not really safe either, right? A two year old
child, I wouldn't want them sucking on a loss hinge. So we're going to rule that one out
as well. Fluoride mouth rinses, well they haven't at two years old developed a coordinated oral
musculature to rinse effectively and to spit out rather than accidentally swallow. So that's
another one that's not really safe for that age range. And same with fluoride toothpaste.
They don't number one have manual dexterity, but even if you were helping them brush their
teeth again, just spitting and not accidentally swallowing a large dose of fluoride, that
would be a concern of mine as well. So fluoride toothpaste again, not really the best option.
It's not the worst option on this list, but it's not the best option either. So the one
that makes the most sense is to deliver a specific small dose of fluoride drops for the patient.
And again, this is because any really, really young child like this would have difficulty
chewing, swallowing, tablets and manipulating these sorts of things. So the answer here
is C. Now if you're really good, I could ask you a bonus question here. How much fluoride
would this person be required per dose? What's the exact dose of fluoride you would prescribe
for this child? So we have this little table that we went over, and if they're not getting
any fluoride, so that's zero PPM, and they're two years old, so that's between six months
and three years, if we go to our fancy chart here, we would be in this column, less than
0.3 PPMs, and we would be between six months to three years, so that would be 0.25 milligrams
of fluoride. Now I'm not going to say you won't get this on the exam because it's possible
that they could ask from this table. So if you have any extra room to memorize some of
this stuff, it could be valuable to get a question or two. So if that were the question
in this case, the answer would be 0.25 milligrams of fluoride. Okay, question number 13, an amalgam
restoration is considered, which of the following? Go ahead and pause the video, and then we'll
go over this one together. Alright, so we can go through this one pretty quickly. Unsafe,
I just kind of threw this one in as a joke. If utilized properly, of course, an amalgam
restoration is certainly a safe material. Primary prevention prevents disease before
it occurs. That's like sealant water fluoridation. Secondary prevention eliminates or reduces
disease after it's occurred. Restoration's are a good example. Tertiary prevention rehabilitates
a patient after the disease process has already taken place. So this is like crowns, bridges,
ranchers, implants, things like that. So an amalgam restoration, composite restoration
would fit in the secondary prevention category. So the answer is B. Alright, so the first
day of the board exam will be 400 questions with these patient management questions, just
like the ones we talked about, sprinkled throughout those 400. And on the second day,
they'll have 100 more questions that are case-based. So they'll give you information
on a patient, background, medical history, clinical photos, x-rays, but otherwise the
questions are very similar. So question 14 and 15, like I've done in the past, will be
examples of questions pertaining to the same patient. So Ryan, young Dr. Ryan, is a young
child who consistently presents as an anxious hypervigilant and upset during dental visits.
Oh, sorry. Ryan is often accompanied by his parent who appears to be very concerned about
the child and wants to be involved at all times in her evaluation and treatment. During
this visit, Ryan's treatment requires an injection and rubber dam application, which
you anticipate may lead to increased anxiety. Rich strategy would be least effective in
completing the rubber dam application. So go ahead, pause the video. You might want
to reread that. I know it's a lot of text. It's a longer question. And let's see what
we can do for her little young Ryan in this question. So go ahead, pause the video, think
through it, and we'll talk about it together. Alright, so what kind of options do we have?
Tell us how do distraction ask her to be helper, structure time, or rehearsals? So which would
be least effective in completing the rubber dam application? Now this might seem like
a little bit of a subjective question, but there is a clear example here based on the
wording. So the key, again, this is, this all comes down to locating the key concept
because a robot isn't generating these questions. This is a human who has created this question
and they have a very clear objective. They want to, they're testing something in specific
and they want to know that you really understand a certain concept, whatever that is. So in
this case, young girl Ryan is an anxious patient. She's very anxious, hyper vigilant, and upset
and you have a helicopter mom who's kind of hovering over treatment. So an anxious patient
is going to benefit from all of these except one in particular. Tell show do is where you
tell the patient what you're going to do. You show them the rubber dam, what it looks
like, let them hold it, it's not scary, and then you actually do it. That's great for
all sorts of patients. So that's certainly something that would be effective. Asking the
child to be a helper is another one of those universal that's always going to be effective
kind of things. Structuring your time, that means like setting, setting boundaries, counting,
making this 10 minutes be about this procedure in the next 10 minutes being about something
else, being very purposeful about what you're trying to accomplish. That's another thing
that's that really you can't go wrong with and rehearsals with them going through maybe
just putting the rubber dam up against their mouth, letting them hold it up against their
mouth to practice something like that. It's another thing that can really help an anxious
patient to get to alleviate some of their anxiety. Here's the one that's not always
great. It can be good but not for an anxious patient because someone who's very hyper-vigilant
who's extremely aware of their surroundings and what's going on, you're not going to
be able to effectively distract somebody who's hyper-vigilant. They're not going to fool
for it. They're not going to be looking at their iPod or their iPad or thinking about
something else. It's much harder to distract this kind of child. The answer in terms of
what would be least effective is distraction. The answer is B. Now for young boy Ryan.
Ryan has a strong gag reflex during x-ray procedures. I actually do. I actually have
a pretty strong gag reflex myself. And you suggest that young boy Ryan takes several
x-ray packets home and practices holding the packets in his mouth for increasingly longer
periods of time. Which of the following techniques does this best exemplify? So go ahead, pause
the video and then we'll go over this last question together. All right, so let's unpack
these answer choices. No pun intended. So social reinforcement. This is about positive
social consequences for them. Now the question prompt gives you a very specific example of
what we're trying to do. We're giving them these x-ray packets to take home with them.
And we're telling them to, we're telling him to stick him in his mouth for increasingly
longer periods of time. Start with a couple seconds, work up to five seconds, ten seconds,
etc. Social reinforcement is not really, this doesn't really correspond with this. So maybe
we're not confident enough to completely roll it out. I'll just give it a question mark for
now. I want to stick, I want to skip to C. Behavioral modeling is learning proper behavior
from role models around you. So this would be like if you, if Ryan had an older brother
who did a really good job with this, it would be modeling his behavior. This is not what
this is about. So we can roll that one out confidently. Guided imagery, that's imagining
a pleasant scene. Imagine being at the beach or Disney World or wherever you really like
to be. That's not at all what this is about either, that we can rule out. Behavioral learning
is, is actually a very wide umbrella of things. This is classical conditioning based on stimuli
and circumstances, like the Pavlov's dogs we talked about before. This also includes
operant conditioning based on rewarding or punishing. And it also overlaps with modeling.
And so this is not, this doesn't have to do with stimuli or rewarding good behavior,
nothing like that. So this isn't behavioral learning either. Systemic desensitization.
I had this in red text, it's also known as graded exposure, which might give away the
answer. But graded exposure or systematic desensitization is exposing a patient to items
from an agreed upon hierarchy of slowly increasing a feared stimuli, allowing them to pair a
relaxation response with a feared stimuli. That's the, the actual definition in layman's
terms. That means you're starting from something less scary and going, building up to something
more scary. So for this patient, if they're, they have a strong gag reflex, a lot of that
can be, can be physical, can be physical stimulation of the nerve. This also can be,
there's a psychological component. And so if you're starting with a very, a very small
amount of time with the x-ray packet, you're starting with maybe a smaller one and working
up to a bigger one. As this question prompt says, we're increasing the, the period of
time that the packets in their mouth. That's a great example of grading that stimuli, starting
from something a little more manageable and going to something a little bit more feared,
scary and not as tolerable. So this is certainly a tricky question, but it's a good example
of systematic desensitization for the patient. So the answer here is B.
All right. So that's it for this video. Thank you so much for watching everyone. I really
hope these practice questions are useful for you as you go through them again. You could
go through, go through them again, flip the questions around and try to reword the questions
to make the other answer choices correct and see how that does. See if you get anything
more out of that. So if you liked this video, please give it a thumbs up, share it with your
friends, subscribe to my channel if you haven't already for more awesome dental prep content.
Thank you so much for watching everyone. If you're interested in supporting my channel and what I do,
please check out my Patreon page. A huge thank you to Michael Rajah, Red Boyd,
Leonilla Banger, David Jaden, Yannett, Nicole, Isabella Caldis, Ali Benjdier, Jacob K and all
of my patrons for their support. You can unlock extras like access to my video slides to take
notes on and practice questions for the board exams in addition to the ones we just went over
here. So go check that out, the link is in the description below. Thanks again for watching everyone.
I'll see you in the next video.